[Music]
this is Education City Stadium it's
pretty easy for fans to get here from
Central Doha because it's only about 10
kilometers away by bus or Metro
[Music]
it's going to be hosting eight games
throughout this tournament now as the
name suggests it is located between many
International and local University and
school campuses and being at the heart
of such an area with so many top brains
from the Arab world you'd expect it to
be cutting edge it certainly looks that
way the 40 000 seater stadiums earn the
nickname diamond in the desert because
of its shape but their substance behind
the sparkle
organizers say this is one of the most
sustainable stadiums in World sport
around 28 of it is made from recycled
materials and you'll notice that the
pitch is below ground it's done on
purpose so that the Rock and the soil
surrounding it prevent this Stadium from
getting too hot less heat means less
energy needed to cool this huge space
down
[Music]
three stadiums to have a sensory room
that provides a quiet space for fans who
might otherwise find a noisy and busy
Stadium a challenging environment
foreign
cup is over this whole top tier will be
dismantled and sent overseas to develop
football over there reducing the
capacity of the stadium to 20 000 seats
[Music]
and this is how the other half will
enjoy this world cup as you can see
we're in the VIP area very comfortable
seats food and drink on tap and if
you're not into football there's also
books on the art of falconry for you to
be able to read now after this world cup
finishes places like this VIP area might
be turned into classrooms for the future
generations to be still able to use this
venue
the last pep talk to take place here
will be ahead of a quarter-final
[Music]
foreign
through this tunnel will come to
represent the end of one of these teams
Journeys at this world cup